alors vous n'avez pas été suivi par
l'assemblée vous au sénat sur sur ce
texte sur deux points particuliers les
contrôles d'identité
les amendes dues par les entreprises qui
ne respecteraient pas tout à fait les
règles j'ai envie de vous demander à
quoi sert le sénat à quoi servait le
sénat dans ce débat là si je pense qu'on
a été suivi sur un certain nombre de
points pas sur tous les points il ya un
point vous n'avez pas souligner nous
avions souhaité dans le premier article
soumettre le pass vaccinale à des
indicateurs parce que nous ce qu'on veut
c'est qu'on ne veut pas que cet
instrument dur dans la permanence on
veut que lorsque l'épidémie aura des
crues on veut que le pass vaccinale soit
caduc les députés ne nous ont pas suivis
qu'est ce que nous allons faire qu'est
ce que nous allons faire nous allons
discuter cet après midi en conférence
des présidents l'idée pourrait être par
exemple il ya plusieurs idées mais de
confier des pouvoirs de commission d'
enquête à la commission des affaires
sociales du sénat qui vérifierait
semaine après semaine les indicateurs
épidémiologique pour dire au
gouvernement très bien on a besoin de
cet outil qu'est le pass vaccinale on
l'a voté tôt que on est constructif on
est positive mais quand cet outil-là
sera devenue disproportionnée ne sera
plus nécessaire alors il faudra
l'arrêter on ne peut pas vivre en france
dans une société du contrôle permanent
quand l'épidémie le réclament alors oui
on déplace le curseur c'est ce que nous
avions fait sur un tout autre champ sur
le terrorisme par exemple il avait fallu
mettre le curseur un peu plus du côté de
la sécurité vis-à-vis des libertés on
l'a fait aussi dans une crise épidémique
mais quand les choses ne sont plus
nécessaires alors de grâce de grâce
faisons en sorte que ça devienne caduc
il y aura au sénat la mise en place
d'une commission d' enquête sur le suivi
d'applications de ce pas actional ça
signifie parce qu'on a une collégialité
voilà par bruno retailleau qui décident
j'ai échangé avec d'autres prisons du
groupe voilà pas forcément de mon bord
du reste ça veut dire que à la
conférence des présidents de cet après
midi c'est une des voies que nous
discuterons les autres
les autres cette voie là d'accord avec
moi ma préférence eh bien ils
s'exprimeront je peux vous dire que en
tout cas plusieurs passagers chance
d'acheter et insulté je pense que ça a
des chances alors la conférence des
présidents en parle l'inscrit et ensuite
c'est votée dans l'hémicycle c'est
l'attribution à la commission des
affaires sociales des pouvoirs de la
commission denquête pourquoi c'est
intéressant parce que ceux qui viennent
et qui sont auditionnés s'ils mentent
ils tombent sous le coup d'un article du
code pénal ça doit les inciter à dire la
vérité ça veut dire que vous au 10e ne
riez des professeurs des représentants
des hôpitaux pour
une idée des critères c'est pas à moi de
faire ce sera la présidente de la
commission des affaires sociales
catherine de roche et puis au rapporteur
qu'elle désignera qui sont désignés de
faire ce choix c'est pas un président de
groupe placé les commissions du sénat
sont des commissions institutionnels
elle travaille en toute indépendance et
les critères seront décidés de la même
manière les critères nous les avions
déjà des films défini je pense que c'est
philippe bas qui avaient porté un
amendement à la commission des lois dont
l'idée vous ne comprenez bien l'idée
c'est pas de fliquer le gouvernement
l'idée c'est simplement qu' on puisse
s'assurer dans une autre enceinte que le
gouvernement c'est ça la démocratie
c'est des pouvoirs et des
contre-pouvoirs que le pass sanitaires
ils durent jusqu'à ce que ce soit
nécessaire quand il n'est plus
nécessaire alors il s'éteint
[Musique]